Літак НАТО приземлився в аеропорту Маркулешти на півночі Молдови.
Досі подібні навчання проводили на румунських або молдовських літаках.
Повітряне судно Північноатлантичного альянсу в маневрах саме такого формату задіяли вперше.
Молдовські та американські військові готуються до зльоту.
За кілька хвилин у небі на висоті 350 метрів один за одним з'являються парашутисти.
У навчаннях беруть участь бійці молдовського спецбатальйону Fulger,
а також службовці Нацармії Молдови та американського спецназу,
дислокованого в Європі - загалом близько 200 осіб.
Ми хочемо, щоб наші військові були навчені в усіх сферах.
Для спецслужб це особливо важливо.
Ці навчання дозволяють нам розвиватися у професійному плані,
вчитися проникати у місце призначення повітряним шляхом.
Як заявили у прес-релізі Національної армії Молдови,
мета навчань - відпрацювання можливостей та підвищення рівня оперативної сумісності військовослужбовців.
Як ви бачили, ми здійснили стрибок із системою парашутної МС-6/T-11.
Відповідно рівень оперативної сумісності з кожним таким навчанням зростає!
Я поставив би високу оцінку цим навчанням.
У майбутньому нам потрібно буде більше співпрацювати, зараз ми працюємо над встановленням зв'язку.
Я вперше у Молдові, вперше стрибаю з молдовськими військовими, і все пройшло чудово!
Майор Катріна Хопкінс була однією з планувальниць цих навчань.
Вона високо оцінила співпрацю молдовських та американських солдатів.
Сполучені Штати та Молдова вперше провели двосторонню повітряно-десантну операцію, яка була дуже успішною.
Однією з ключових цілей і завдань для армії США в Європі
була робота над нашою взаємосумісністю з молдовськими партнерами.
Ми мали можливість вчитися у молдовських майстрів стрибків
і навчати наших майстрів стрибків, як вони проводять повітряно-десантні операції.
І водночас це дозволило нам як Сполученим Штатам працювати з ними,
щоб продемонструвати їм, як ми працюємо.
До кордону з Одеською областю звідси приблизно 90 км.
Ще ближче - Придністров'я, де вже понад 30 років розміщені російські військові.
Війна в Україні змусила молдовську владу всерйоз замислитися про стан армії.
З часів здобуття незалежності республіки її чисельність скоротилася майже вчетверо,
а оснащенню підрозділів практично не приділяли уваги,
аргументуючи це нейтральним статусом країни.
Перший знак, що поштовх стався, це, по-перше, подвоєння бюджету Нацармії.
Далі це видно з інтенсивності співпраці з НАТО і Євросоюзом саме в оборонній сфері,
а не тільки в політичній.
Набагато більше стало різних навчань.
А також, про що повідомляє міністерство оборони, закупівля певного радара.
Це означає, що підвищуються та з'являються нові засоби оборони.
Такі навчання, на думку колишнього військового представника Молдови в НАТО та ЄС Раду Бурдужа,
є надбанням для оборонного потенціалу Республіки Молдова.
У проєкті нової стратегії безпеки Республіки Молдова ясно зазначено,
що Національна армія є одним із пріоритетів.
І сектор національної оборони є одним із пріоритетів.
По-друге, ці навчання сприяють поліпшенню інтероперабельності
та сумісності військових структур між різними країнами,
між нашою національною армією та армією країн-партнерів.
І, по-третє, через ці навчання Республіка Молдова
готує свої контингенти для участі в різних миротворчих операціях.
Це наш внесок у регіональну безпеку.
Крім того, нейтральний статус Молдови не забороняє їй зміцнювати обороноздатність.
Нейтралітет - це не означає ізоляція.
Нейтралітет, навпаки, означає, що ми маємо більше коштів виділяти на обороноздатність.
Ми повинні тісніше співпрацювати з нашими партнерами,
тому що нейтралітет залишає тебе практично віч-на-віч з твоїм противником.
Якщо дивишся, порівнюєш сили та засоби Російської Федерації як потенційної загрози
та Республіки Молдова, то вони непорівнювані.
Якщо дивитися короткостроково, то зараз реальної загрози немає.
Якщо дивитися на період від двох років і більше -
ніхто нічого не може виключати, тому ми маємо готуватися.
Нині ця концепція нейтралітету сильно підірвана.
Після того, що сталося з Україною, дві традиційно нейтральні країни - Фінляндія та Швеція -
одразу попросилися до НАТО.
Нещодавно Генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг заявив про поглиблення партнерства
з Молдовою на тлі тиску, який чиниться на республіку Росією.
Столтенберг оголосив про фінансову допомогу країні для зміцнення її кіберзахисту,
стратегічних комунікацій та підвищення оборонного потенціалу.
А Молдова у свою чергу виявила бажання взяти участь у міжнародних місіях та навчаннях.